what's going on guys this is Rob and in
this video we're going to cover the
origin of Victor timely or an alternate
Persona of Kane the Conqueror why
because Kings and the MCU and we're
dealing with the Multiverse Saga which
means we're dealing with an infinite
number of variants of characters so
we're going to cover as many variants of
Kang as we possibly can and Victor
timely is one of the Lesser known so I
figure that'd be kind of a cool thing to
cover here so here's the idea of Victor
timely and what I'm about to tell you
here is something that we are going to
reiterate in future videos but I'm going
to give you guys the quick and dirty
explanation on the history of Kank so
the idea behind this is that King was
just a guy named Nathaniel Richards who
lived in the future and life was boring
because every problem that could be
solved was solved and so in order to
basically make life unboring for himself
he discovered doctor Doom's time
platform and then traveled back to the
days of ancient Egypt in an effort to
conquer all of reality he was defeated
by The Fantastic Four during that time
of course he named himself Rama Tut and
then after his defeat By the Fantastic
Four he was supposed to go back to his
own time but he ended up Landing in the
20th century and then started calling
himself Scarlet Centurion after
designing a suit of armor that was
modeled after doctor Doom's suit the
relationship between Doctor Doom and
King is a little finicky right sometimes
he's descended from Doctor Doom other
times Marvel will say he's definitely
descended from Reed Richards we don't
really know marvel never gave us a
definitive answer but the important
thing here is that he was defeated yet
again this time he was defeated by The
Avengers this led to him fleeing back to
his own time but overshooting by a
thousand years and so when he landed on
Earth in that future what you had was
Humanity that was exceedingly primitive
surrounded by super advanced technology
and so Nathaniel harnessed the
technology conquered the entirety of the
earth and then changed his name to Kane
the Conqueror and then following that he
starts bouncing back and forth through
time trying to find a way to conquer
Earth what ends up happening here and
what this tells us in terms of Victor
timely is it brings in something called
the chronopolis and what it tells us is
that following his first defeat at the
hands of the Avengers presumably when he
was Scarlet Centurion and before he fled
back to well at least was supposed to go
back to his own time he founded
chronopolis and chronopolis is literally
just just a giant technological City
that exists out there but is displaced
from the time stream it's technically
considered to be out of phase with the
normal main Marvel Universe all that
means is you can't see it and you can't
enter into it only somebody like Kane
can do that so it's a little weird and
it's a it's a little wonky you know how
the flash basically changes his
vibration to go from one Universe to the
next it's that exact same thing in terms
of being at a phase so it's like if the
entire Marvel Universe were colored red
that being out of phase or the
chronopolis is colored blue so all Kang
has to do is change his color from red
to blue and then he can enter into
chronopolis the best explanation I can
possibly offer off the cuff that's
non-confusing but the important thing
here is that with the establishment of
chronopolis what Kang wanted to do was
position himself at a time when he could
manipulate the entirety of the 20th
century instead of just showing up and
trying to kill all the superheroes the
best thing to do was influence
technological advancements over the
course of the 20th century so he could
effectively control them all think of it
like a kind of back door to modern day
technology a via first that he could use
that he could basically control all
technology that exists in the world the
way in which he did this was using his
time travel device to appear in some
little Backwater town in upstate
Wisconsin and that when he appeared here
he basically fashioned himself the name
Victor timely and then presented himself
as an inventor that was on par with
Henry Ford and Thomas Edison the latter
is a poor choice because Thomas Edison
stole all his technology from Tesla so
the thing about this is that by
operating under the name of Victor
timely and then building factories and
providing industry to this town and then
building up its wealth as well as its
popularity in the United States He in
turn renamed the town to timely so he
named it after himself and then doing
that what Kang started to realize is
that he can't stay as Victor timely
forever that if he were to stay Victor
timely and stay youthful people would
start asking questions because from the
perspective of the town he's just a
regular guy who's really good when it
comes to inventing stuff and so over
time what he started doing was going
back to chronopolis and then of course
sort of watching the time stream to a
degree making sure that his changes or
the modifications that he was making
were impacting the timeline the way he
was supposed to but what also ended up
taking place is that following the quote
unquote death of Victor timely due to
old age suddenly his son Victor timely
Jr appeared and that of course was Kane
the conquer just replacing himself as
Victor timely and then just kept doing
that over and over and over again with
no one being any the wiser of the fact
that he was secretly operating as not
only Victor timely but the different
descendants of Victor timely and in fact
Victor timely Jr actually had a run-in
with Phineas Horton who worked at timely
corporation which was ran by Victor
timely Jr now Phineas Horton is
exceedingly important in the landscape
of Marvel Comics he's the guy who
created the original Human Torch so
those are the guys this is a really cool
Easter egg for the Marvel Cinematic
Universe if you guys remember Captain
America the First Avenger when Steve
Rogers all emaciated and everything goes
to the Stark Expo there's like this
brief moment where the camera is like
panning and then you see what looks like
a flaming guy inside of a giant
containment device that's the original
Human Torch Jim Hammond that was built
by Phineas Horton right it was basically
the Human Torch before Johnny Storm but
the thing about this is that Phineas
Horton working it timely gave him not
just the intelligence or at least the
Boost to intelligence but also the
resources to build the Human Torch and
the result of this is that he eventually
left timely and that's when he built Jim
Hammond so it's one of those things
where it's kind of in a lot of ways came
to conquer as Victor timely influencing
everything that went on in the 20th
century not only that every form of
Technology that's currently utilized
across the world in the modern era in
Marvel Comics technology utilized by
Reed Richards and the Fantastic Four
Prosthetics the whole nine yards that's
all because of Victor timely they came
to conqueror really does control almost
all forms of technology across the world
now this story was also written way back
in the day there really hasn't been an
instance as far as I'm aware of where
King has utilized that and basically
shut down all technology across the
world and then seize control of it which
really makes you wonder why he hasn't
done that yet but nonetheless that's the
origin of Victor timely not the most
important version of Kane there ever was
but one of the different variations of
Kang that does exist out there so with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end thank you all for
watching and I will catch you all later
peace